the Home Secretary this afternoon events
at the wheel now causing her grief
sowella bravaman was caught speeding
last summer and according to the Sunday
Times asked civil servants and an
advisor to try and arrange a private
speed awareness course instead of
attending a regular group session when
this was refused she instead took the
points and paid a fine
the Prime Minister unaware of the
penalty until this weekend seeming
frustrated to be asked about it did you
have any questions about the summit I'm
ducking the question of whether he had
full confidence in his Home Secretary I
don't know the full details of what has
happened nor have I spoken to the Home
Secretary I think you can see firsthand
what I've been doing over the last day
or so but I understand that she's
expressed regret for speeding accepted
the penalty and paid the fine number 10
later said the Prime Minister did have
confidence in Sue Ella bravaman labor
calling for an inquiry into whether the
ministerial code had been breached
Zoella Bravo and Scott got form on this
hasn't she you'll remember she actually
had to resign as home secretary under
Liz truss because she sent confidential
documents to a Tory MP when she
shouldn't have done that and Rishi sunak
reappointed her critics say asking civil
servants here at the home office to deal
with personal affairs would be against
the rules while some suggest to El
abroad them was trying to avoid being
publicly identified by attempting to
arrange a private course those close to
her site security issues and say her
Protection Team would have needed to
come to any group session this comes at
a tense time for the Home Secretary
who's no stranger to controversy
in her Hampshire seat today little
sympathy from voters if I did it or
anybody else did it and we were given a
fine or whatever we wouldn't have any
other options the same as any other
citizen in the UK she should pay the
fine I don't think the right wing of the
Tory party wants to see her go and she
has her their full support
a polarizing figure Suella bravaman
frustrated some party colleagues this
week with a Punchy and personal speech
at a right-wing conference
Under Pressure over migration too it all
makes for a tense political backdrop
from which embarrassing stories often
more easily emerge
of our Sky News